bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france associations partis politiques
journalistes ou encore citoyen lambda
jugent cette loi sur la sécurité globale
en tout cas l'article 24 est considéré
comme étant inutiles liberticide qui
porte atteinte à la liberté d'informer
quel est votre regard
alors nous on est plutôt favorable à
cette loi parce qu'il ya un vrai enjeu
de protéger nos forces de l'ordre on l'a
vu notamment le double meurtre aux
terroristes à magnanville et bien il ya
une vraie il veut demander une vraie
nécessité de protéger davantage nos
forces de l'ordre
cet article 24 avait une incertitude sur
la liberté de la presse a priori a été
réécrit dans la nuit pour justement levé
tous les doutes et faire en sorte que
justement les journalistes qui
continuent à faire leur travail
donc ça va plutôt dans le bon sens non
on est favorable à plus tôt à cette loi
il faut aller plus loin il faut armer
les policiers municipaux on a vu
notamment au moment de la nôtre tenta de
nice que c'est cette police l'a7 plus de
proximité qui est en première ligne et
qui peut intervenir le plus rapidement
et puis surtout ça permet de décharger
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
deux missions qui sont pas essentiels
pour vraiment les focaliser sur
l'essentiel
est ce que c'est à la police nationale
et la gendarmerie ne contrôler les
personnes sur des attestations cas ce
seront aux torrents plis pour pouvoir
circuler
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
alors le fait de protéger davantage les
forces de l'ordre mais pas tellement
remise en question ce qui fait débat
aujourd'hui c'est surtout la tentation
de remettre en cause la liberté
d'informer c'est ce que disent les
opposants au texte gérald a maintenant
les miss de l'intérieur a quand même
évoqué la possibilité que les
journalistes se déclare auprès de la
préfecture pour couvrir les
manifestations alors il est revenu sur
ses propos en expliquant que ce ne
serait pas obligatoire mais c'est quand
même du jamais vu une telle proposition
c'est la partie de la loi et la volonté
du gouvernement s'inquiète plus
dangereuses et girel que c'est plus
globale s'est pas uniquement la liberté
de la presse qu'on a un candidat
emmanuel macron qu'avait que s'étaient
déclarés comme libérale
tous les aspects d'ailleurs qui devait
favoriser la liberté est finalement dans
le concret on s'aperçoit que la liberté
de la presse et c'est plus ou moins une
tentative être entravé la liberté de
circuler des concitoyens a été fortement
entravée avec les de confinement la
liberté d'entreprendre est volé en
éclats avec le confinement notamment
avec les petits commerces que c'est
surtout les petites pme les commerçants
et c'est pas les grandes entreprises qui
vont le plus souffrir de sautes
confinement et même la liberté de
propriété quand on voit les positions
qu'on était un peu ubuesque sur les
squatters dans l'actualité cet été on a
finalement 1
un président qui doit être garant des
institutions et des libertés
fondamentales et qui failli à sa mission
première qui est de garantir la liberté
qui a été en plus en partie élue sur
cette question des libertés
donc c'est là où il ya le problème et
puis on a un gouvernement qui perd pied
et qui part dans des dérives
administratif qui n'ont ni queue ni tête
c'est totalement absurde c'est un la
biture distant pour reprendre le terme
un article allemands ont fait des des
lois oncle est de plus en plus de textes
une prothèse de mangeant moins en moins
pour pour finalement contrôlé de plus de
plus en plus les métiers liberté on ne
sait pas si on va avoir le droit ou non
d'acheter son sapin de noël ces
guirlandes et boules de noël quel
week-end ou l'autre pour venir sur sept
ce projet de loi cet article 24 est ce
que selon vous il ya une réelle
intention ou alors c'est là surtout une
question de forme une maladresse une
improvisation parce qu'au sein même de
la majorité le texte fait débat mais la
ministre de la culture prend ses
distances avec son collègue de
l'intérieur
le tout est permis j'espère que c'est
une maladresse mais c'est si c'est une
maladresse c'est pas pour autant
rassurant et ça ça prouve l'amateurisme
de ce gouvernement qui est pas capable
de faire face à la crise et une
situation qui est de plus en plus
anxiogène
le président de la république n'est pas
capable de rassurer on connaît pas le
cap seront grands discours du 14 juillet
pour justement se réinventer et avec un
plan de relance pour rassurer l'économie
vole en éclats avec le second
confinement et finalement c'est emmanuel
macron devient davantage le président de
l'incertitude
que de la protection des français donc
c'est relativement inquiétant j'espère
que c'est que c'est plutôt une
approximation du gouvernement qu'une
volonté réelle de museler la presse mais
dans les deux cas ce n'est pas rassurant
alors vous vous dites favorables à ce
texte en matière de protection des
policiers les forces de l'ordre est ce
que le texte sur ce point là très
précisément va assez loin selon vous
est-ce qu'il est suffisant il permet de
régler une partie du problème et on
règle pas le problème qui est celui de
la symétrie de l'image ce qu il faut
pouvoir permettre à chacun de filmer et
préserver les libertés ses propos
précédents mais justement ce qui va
permettre justement de d'éviter ces
lynchages et de rétablir une forme de
vérité ou du moins de fournir à la fois
les images des gens qui fument et les
images des policiers et un réel enjeu de
permettre aux policiers de quand ils
sont en opération d'avoir des caméras de
de généraliser ce processus pour avoir à
la fois les deux images les deux côtés
pas avoir d seulement des partis et
avoir plus on a d'information et plus de
plus de transparence
on a de risques de dérives d'un côté
comme de l'autre merci d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions
aimerait glissait directeur de la
communication du think tank le
millénaire